et parlons politique à présent nous
allons revenir sur un sujet qui a fait
l'actualité cette année dans notre
département avec William l bonsoir
William alors vous êtes avec moi ce soir
pour nous parler de la fusion
départementale entre les Yvelines et les
hautes scènes tout à fait Floran
souvenez-vous tout a commencé en janvier
2016 le département des Yvelines et
celui des haut scèes avaient choisi de
mutualiser leur cérémonie de vœux pour
la nouvelle année une cérémonie qui
s'était tenue au Haras de jardis dans le
92 et durant laquelle avait été faite
l'annonce officielle du projet de fusion
des deux départements on écoute
l'interview de Pierre Bédier à l'époque
c'est de faire de la mutualisation en
faisant des choses qu'on faisait chacun
de notre côté en les faisant ensemble ça
coûtera moins cher un exemple c'est pour
ça qu'on commence par les routes les
appels d'offrees qu'on fera concerneront
deux départements donc forcément les
entreprises pour les avoir seront
obligés de baisser leur prix et cette
mutualisation va générer des économies
qui vont être affectés à modérer la
pression fiscale et à financer le
développement économique il y a pas de
politique sociale possible sans
développement économique l'objectif est
donc de réaliser des économies
exactement ce projet de fusion c'est une
conséquence des bêes des baisses de
dotations de l'État selon le département
les Yvelines auraient perdu près de 90 %
de sa dotation global de fonctionnement
qui serait passé de 145 millions d'euros
en 2013 à 13 millions d'euros en 2017
soit une perte totale de 132 millions
dans son budget en 4 ans le
rapprochement des deux territoires
serait donc un moyen de mutualiser les
service et donc de réaliser des
économies pour les deux départements ce
que nous avons vu c'était en janvier
aujourd'hui où en sommes-nous de cette
fusion alors pour l'instant la fusion
n'est pas encore enfin n'est encore
qu'un projet on parlerait plus d'un
trait d'union entre les deux
départements et ce trait d'union il a
pris la forme d'un ay un établissement
public de coordination
interdépartementale qui a été créé le 23
mars 2016 et dont Patrick de vijan a
pris la présidence on n'est pas encore
dans une fusion on est simplement dans
un processus de rap rochement nous avons
un instrument pour travailler ensemble
et déterminer ce que pourra être dans
l'avenir une fusion si nous réussissons
à l'amener à son terme nous avançons pas
à pas avec pragmatisme et aussi de
grande détermination parce que nous
sommes vraiment convaincus que la région
parisienne est en panne elle est en
panne de développement économique et que
l'association de ces deux départements
c'est une réponse d'intérêt général cet
établissement public de coopération
interdépartementale et donc composé des
conseillers départementaux des deux
départements au total donc 88 personnes
alors quelles sont les premières actions
le pays pour l'instant ne s'est réuni
que deux fois la première pour élire son
bureau et ses différentes commissions
dans lesquelles on retrouve l'action
sociale la culture l'environnement
laavirie ou encore le développement
économique pour voir la liste complète
je vous invite à vous rendre sur le site
internet de le pays alors dans les
premières actions désormais engagé il y
a la création d'un service
interdépartemental d' archéologie
préventive qui a été voté le 15 avril on
retrouve aussi pour les transports le
projet de mise en commun des services
d'entretien et d'exploitation du réseau
routier départemental la mutualisation
et l'optimisation des achats a été elle
aussi votée le 15 avril le 30 juin
dernier lors de sa 2e réunion le pays a
voté la fusion de ces deux sociétés
mixtes d'aménagement la SEM 92 et
Eveline aménagement qui deviennent
caliios un aménageur public au service
des collectivités ces missions ça va
être d'être
des communes en particulier et de leur
apporter toutes les compétences avec en
même temps toute la réflexion que nous
allons conduire et qui sera une
réflexion qui sera plutôt dans une
philosophie de liberté des collectivités
local que dans celle du la
centralisation
étatiste développée par grand pareil
aménagement ce matin donc nous avons
pris des des décisions importantes
autour de l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire pour être
bref simple clair c'est la construction
de logement et d'équipement la
construction de logement pour loger les
ivelinois les altosekanis et les
équipements qui vont avec ces
constructions de logement également au
menu de cette dernière réunion le vote
du budget primitif 2016 et la création
d'un budget annexe un budget qualifié de
Light par son président d'un montant de
446000 € consacrés pour l'essentiel à
l'archéologie préventive voilà comme le
disent les deux présidents des
départements cette pays qu'il qualifie
d'historique avance pas à pas avec pour
objectif évidemment de réaliser des
économies une fusion totale qui
n'arrivera peut-être jamais mais en tout
cas un rapprochement déjà bien engagé
sujet que nous suivrons merci beaucoup à
vous William